hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand land waifu and today we
are all about people doing the
unexpected that's right it's all about
bam boom boom
let's get into episodes 104 and 105.
episode 104 was about
mercy well depending on perspective or
maybe
not actually it was mercy all round mary
and pippin continued their game with
mary still trying to beat her and not
understanding why he doesn't feel
humiliated at the number of times he's
lost which is
substantial he's learning fun and while
shia labata free picks up on and
is concerned by the effect our little
game is having on him
he's not anywhere near as concerned as
he should be if you ask my opinion which
i mean you're listening to this so you
kind of do mirom seems to be gaining
some humanity which oddly isn't
something he got to have in life he's
enjoying spending time with the kid and
he's enjoying learning about the history
of the game for the kid whether that
means he likes her
or likes her connection to the game or
likes the game that she has to keep
playing as a result we're not sure but
she's the first person he's allowed to
keep talking that long and so he shows
her the mercy of allowing her to rest
before essentially cheating to see if
that makes a difference to her playstyle
because what else do we call it when
someone has an unfair advantage in a
game
he can't win fairly so eventually in
theory
she'll fail because she'll get tired
this is a game
of strategy and up till now he's been
pretty good at beating his opponents not
just to be the best but to learn how to
think steps ahead of them
up till now his opponents have needed to
be at their best to match him
she doesn't need this advantage and he's
played for days without food to get to
this point it's a phenomenal distraction
and it's now that i realize her colour
palette is very similar to natero's
i have no idea if there is a connection
but i just want you to know it's
something i've seen
you know in case i'm foretelling
something we have yet to see
exactly what the tarot does beyond look
at boobies so i'm suspicious even if it
comes to nothing we haven't seen him
since he was sitting
golden upon a plinth and this kind of
behavior reeks of him so you know
i'm watching anyway mercy was given by
the kid too
well briefly in fact actually she showed
more mercy than marowam
rather than taking that victory
immediately she gave it a moment to sit
in the fullness of its existence before
ending it with a wonderfully simple
finality
what mary also knows now is that he's 10
years behind her still
the fascination he's experiencing is
breaking through all the previous
experiences of humans he's had
possibly even while actually human in
allowing her to speak for so long it's
almost as though he conceded power to
her when i think back to how pito owned
his respect this kid has done the same
he knows he could kill her instantly but
she's currently sort of a wikipedia
rabbit hole
as long as she's alive he's still
learning how to overcome an enemy even
if he's forgotten why he started playing
these games in the first place the
second he took the game
off the board it became perfectly clear
who was in charge she didn't even flinch
in telling him the story behind the move
that she'd had to crush it herself and
what to him would be combat and how glad
she was to see it renewed in this moment
she showed him that history repeating
itself could be beautiful
and she did it as a child there have
been a lot of dead children in this arc
and the fact that a child could also be
his undoing is very smooth finishing the
arc as it begins with a confrontation
between a child and a monster gives us
a nice cycle we just didn't expect it to
be a child we haven't even learned the
name of has someone learned the name of
it
because i feel like i'm just behind i
don't know what i'm missing
anyway i do wonder whether marouane will
ever actually ask her name there's a
part of me wondering at what point he
decides to offer her the privilege of
humanity or
chimera antness i guess humans only tend
to offer names to those creatures we
intend to care for
and the names tend to reflect the
significance we place on them she
doesn't seem to be a pet to him so why
would she need a name
she's also not an equal but a combatant
one he keeps losing to with dignity she
offers back to him with every match
he's consumed with her mind so consumed
he forgets her physical disabilities and
engages on a more real level than he has
with anyone in possibly two lifetimes
which is quite touching
though it probably shouldn't be speaking
of touching we have
chitu being a failure at picking games
he can win
i wish i had more to say about that but
i really don't other than to question
where he was hiding the magazine
what makes a cheetah chimera ant laugh
and why did morel let him
go that last one is the most important
why let him go when he had him trapped
he's adding to his load later
potentially
i want to talk more about this situation
but it's really hard because there was
no subtlety in it it really was just
chitu being a complete
nonce and morale letting him go because
he is actually a complete nonce
oh i guess it's worth discussing the
idea that at the point of last resort
it's possible to develop a new power
that's new and it's interesting and
suggest it could happen to anyone though
though whether the power is of any use
is also to be seen and then we have the
narrator turning up which is making me
wonder whether tagashi in writing these
pieces had just given up on the idea of
inner monologues
or something happened that meant that he
couldn't draw them as fully as he wanted
to
because it used to be shown not told and
now we're having a lot of
information told to us david
attenborough style and while that's not
bad
we've shifted style from that internal
depth we had in previous arcs and even
this one up until kilwa was freed from
his brother's pinheaded curse
and i would have liked to know what nov
is thinking as he catches the security
bug i want to know the internals of that
lion
as well because frankly i'm not sure
what he's doing but i think it's fair to
share that information with us
all i know is that there are hijinks and
i want to know what they are
because they're hijinks that are
supposed to be for me hijinks i say
give me more of that in episode 105. so
here we are in episode
wait hang on yeah i can do this better
so here we are in episode 105 where
there is some odd behavior that almost
looks like
mary has the beginnings of a crush and
is annoyed by it
beyond that we had an exchange of power
this episode one that everyone noticed
it's a really odd thing thinking about
the dynamic between meruem and i'm gonna
say komugi because
that's what crunchyroll told me she
keeps telling him he holds the power
that he is the supreme leader and yet
when violin butterfree noted that the
game had come
off the board i don't think he'd ever
returned to the board mary's been
consumed with it from
that moment to now when he decides that
not only can he not beat her
in this game but that there is nothing
he can do to frighten her beyond hurting
himself and there's a wonderful play in
that because as he hurts himself to make
the point that he is ruthlessly fair and
both the kid and his guard rebel against
him
it's the kid who takes control of the
space he can't hurt her he listens to
her story and hears how little she cares
about her own life
how little importance she places in it
how much she believes she is a burden
and that touches that tiny bit of
humanity at the core of that person for
the first time we just didn't see his
eyes
possibly because he was having an
emotion the enjoyment of the game
the hesitation to kill both are signs of
humanity that he has to think
very carefully and deeply about that
butterboy makes a concession and he's
about to kill the guard but she saves
his life too
both of them owe a life debt to her now
technically
and isn't that fun and if it turns out
that the kid uses nen somehow and the
conditions were that they need to owe a
debt or lose at goongi or hell
even hear how useless she is to her
family they've heard all those things
now
ultimately mary's found someone who has
so little to lose that he's not sure how
to interact with her
how do you a strong and powerful warrior
whose primary tactic to this point has
been his ability to
hurt others physically hurt someone
who's not afraid
of death not only doesn't fear it but
welcomes it if
he doesn't get his way which introduces
another question really doesn't it if he
figures out how to beat her she'll be
left in a worse situation where she'll
be begging for him to kill her the
question from there is whether or not he
would whether he'll deliberately lose
and whether
knowing the stakes for her now if she
would accept a loss if he faked it they
both know each other's movements now and
she's learned the way that he reacts and
has shown that she can fight against it
as noted the game moved away from the
board she very specifically put it back
there into a situation that she could
manage
she could control the board in a way
that she couldn't control any other
situation and i wonder then how
she would react if she could see whether
she could manipulate the world
the way that she manipulates that board
the mind of a strategist is a very
powerful thing could she even live
outside of the game world if
he said he would hire her as a
strategist and how fascinating it is
that i can even consider he would do
something like that
it feels like he trusts her to be
predictable and possibly even loyal
if by loyal we mean dedicated to the
same goals as he is
or as ruthlessly focused on an outcome
as he is
like he said he's not even as dedicated
as she is didn't even consider that she
could ask for his life and then
rips his arm off to prove that you know
i would have done it if you'd said that
cause like i'm strong which is kind of
sweet do we call that sweet here darling
take my arm for we made a deal and i
lived my word
like is that do we do we class that as
sweet or did he do it to frighten her
and if he did and expected her to change
her mind based on the stress involved he
didn't get that either and that's even
more disrupting it seems like this kid
knows his rhythm now and
now we know that there is tension in his
healing that those on the outside know
about because of the amount of energy
and time it takes to fix
flesh are with two to three hours to
recovery
who knows what's going to happen we've
been given a time frame and
psychologically when you have a time
frame you begin to track it
you track that time even loosely you
have something in relation to something
else so all these behaviors begin to
seem simultaneous and all of them gain a
level of tension and while these things
go on inside
outside we have we have corporate guy
nov
dressing as a freaking tree this entire
sequence was hugely tense and with all
the knowledge laid on us by the narrator
we know that something's gonna fall
apart
at least once something i imagine a
number of somethings because once palm's
in that vicinity and finds out that nov
has been killed or some such
she's not gonna be pleased and we know
what happens when palm is displeased
well
gone does anyway i wonder if palm's
gonna save the world hopefully she'll at
least deal with that awful secretary no
back to nov who has leaves in his
pockets in
his pockets in his pockets look at his
pockets
he's gonna leave i just i mean that the
attention to detail here is quite
quite superb i wish i had a better way
to end this
if you enjoyed this mishmash of words
and maybe some of the order of them hit
like share subscribe tell your friends
hit the bell click the things on the
screen and i'll see you
next time